[Music]
hey new york
there's a lot of stuff that happened
since the last season of the show ended
you had to spend a whole lot of time
inside
and got really close with
just a handful of people
you got really good at cutting your own
hair
and discovered exciting new ways to
entertain yourself
but you still found a way to show up for
work every day
and treated yourself to a vacation
whenever it felt safe
and just when you thought that things
were going back to normal
the nightmare just seemed to continue
a lot of people thought that we wouldn't
be able to make another season of the
show
but we did
and it still has all your favorite stuff
from the first one
new york looks more interesting right
now than it ever has before
and even though you lost
a lot of what you loved
it really made you appreciate what you
still have
so don't be upset if you feel like you
missed anything along the way
because
you don't always realize you're in the
middle of history
until it's over
[Applause]
[Applause]
this is john wilson
talk to you soon
you